I come from Earth a planet about laws my
name is Peter quill there's one other
name you might know me by star-lord if
you've ever gone to IMAX to see anything
about space you can get deep this is
space and imagination fusing in a way
that's colorful brilliant
I'm the big experienced guy especially
if it's an epic film the movie looks
amazing the world that that they built
is huge
when I go see an IMAX movie that's
really made to be in that format that's
when it really makes a theater-going
experience perfect we crafted it you
know specifically for the IMAX
experience you had like a
hyper-intelligent perfectionist tweaking
every single frame of this movie there's
this pod chase sequence that is so
unbelievable I'm watching this thing my
mind's blown
the SATs that were bail that were real
they don't look like they're just
separated from what the actors are doing
I guess we're stuck together partners oh
yeah it's visually unlike anything you
have ever seen in your life
you do want to see it in IMAX in order
for you to appreciate it in its entirety
I felt very fortunate to have the
opportunity to create something that was
meant for audiences to go to and enjoy
together it's a lot of laughs and some
drama might even shed a few tears it's a
visual feast you kind of have to see it
in IMAX